[Music]
all right now the media mob's shameless
malpractice is on full display again
tonight as the major sunday shows guess
what they largely ignored the
assassination attempt last week against
justice kavanaugh that means abc cbs nbc
also other outlets like the new york
times they barely covered the story even
prompting scorn from hbo's bill maher
hardly a conservative take a look
the new york times buried this yeah it
was like anything below the fold if this
had been a liberal supreme court justice
that someone came to kill
it would have been on the it would have
been on the front page and that's what's
so disappointing about a paper like the
new york times
because they just wear their bias on
their sleeves and they if it's not part
of something that feeds our narrative
and their protest
here with reaction outnumbered co-host
kaylee mcaney along with former arkansas
governor mike huckabee who is about to
be displaced as the former best governor
in arkansas uh as his daughter i expect
will win that race handily uh kaley let
me start with you this is a big story
it's an assassination plot against a
supreme court justice then we have
the approval of the biden white house
then gensake
and chuck schumer threatening on the
steps of the u.s supreme court gorsuch
and and kavanaugh
and they seem okay with that oh we're
fine as long as they're peaceful if i
start giving out the addresses of
liberals that i don't like and something
happens uh do you think i'm going to be
the one that gets blamed for it i would
think so
i would think so that's called doxing
you would be blamed 100 sean but the
reason the media is ignoring it is
because oh wait the president of the
united states is ignoring it yes his
press secretary put out a statement but
where is president biden's voice on this
it's been almost seven days his press
secretary went out there erroneously
today and said the president himself has
condemned this he has not condemned this
in fact he said that if this decision
dobbs comes out the way we all think it
will there will be a revolution there is
such a double standard when i was at the
podium and i'm sure governor huckabee
knows when sarah was we were asked to
condemn every single episode of violence
big small
whatever even if it had nothing to do
with the president so much so i had an
entire tab in my binder called violence
that was just pages and pages of all of
the times president trump condemned
racism anti-semitism violence bigotry
but this white house is a different
standard joe can just be silent as by
the way 13
uh pro-life facilities have been either
firebombed or vandalized alongside this
threat and by the way it's got that's
gotten very little coverage also
governor your take on it uh
i under no circumstances would i ever
put
anybody's address out publicly so people
would know where it is doxxing as they
call it
or encourage people to protest in front
of the home of a justice now it does
raise issues regarding the law are they
trying to intimidate are they trying to
harass the justices into voting a
certain way it certainly seems like that
to me
sean it's domestic terrorism pure and
simple it's trying to scare people into
a different behavior than you expect
them to do
can can i just say do you know there's
one thing that is worse than not
enforcing the law and by the way it is
against federal law to go to the home of
a supreme court justice in protest it's
against the federal law so it's not
being enforced i don't care what mayor
garland says he's doing a lot of things
but he's not enforcing the law but
there's something worse than not
enforcing the law sean and that's only
enforcing the law against your political
enemies
that's what's really disturbing that we
see peter navarro gets arrested strip
searched put in leg shackles and
handcuffed at an airport
eric holder doesn't you constantly see a
different set of rules being applied to
people who are conservative versus the
people who are on the far left and who
are doing
just illegal things in supreme court
justices homes and that's what we need
to
really we have been watching this unfold
for a long time we don't have equal
justice under the law and we don't have
equal application of our law that now is
a fact and we saw that you know talk
about the new york times and the
the ignoring of this case uh they for
three long years they even got pulitzers
they need to give back they lied about
trump russia collusion none of which was
true governor and they never get held
accountable for that part either
and you're right about the law part it's
against the law to intimidate and harass
a judge or justice
and and i think we have to start
demanding that the law be not only
enforced but enforced equally regardless
of someone's political view all those
people arrested after january 6
you called for them to suffer the full
judgment of the law if they in fact hurt
someone or vandalized and every other
conservative i know did the same thing
because we believe in true law and order
applied equally we do not hear that from
the left and yet we have violent threats
against kavanaugh we have it against amy
comey barrett we've already seen against
steve scalise who almost was killed by
an assassin's bullet and the attack by a
a crazy guy against
his own neighbor rand paul
and and kaylee all this attention
january 6 that was one riot okay i
condemned it in real time on radio i
condemned it that night on tv we are all
consistent all right but i also
condemned all
574 riots in the summer of 2020 dozens
died thousands of cops injured billions
of property damage we have all of the
video evidence you would ever want to
arrest every one of those people and yet
pretty much from what i've heard in most
of the cities where this happened
nobody's being held accountable so which
goes to governor huckabee's point
exactly in fact in portland and i
remember this because i followed this
news each and every night because i was
at the podium at the time
there were officers locked in a
courthouse and you had rioters attempt
to burn those officers alive inside this
courthouse they were federal officers
well as it turns out the department of
justice under merrick garland has
dropped one-third of the cases
against the portland rioters so where is
the justice for them where are the
justice for the dozens as you mentioned
who were killed many more injured
businesses grazed to the ground david
dorn that officer uh who we all know and
love we've covered his story who lost
his life amid those riots there must be
accountability and there's no reason to
drop a third of cases against portland
rioters all right don't forget kaylee's
on outnumbered every day right here on
the fox news channel and sarah huckabee
sanders will be the new governor of
arkansas is my prediction i hope i'm
right when we come back three
pennsylvania parents now are taking
legal action to stop transgender related
lessons at their kids elementary school
pete heg seth has written a book
detailing how you can protect your kids
from the left's woke agenda and
indoctrination along with laura trump as
we continue hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else